[Musik]
das geistige und das materielle sind nur
verschiedene erscheinungsformen einer
einzigen umfassenden wirklichkeit
diese auffassung vertrat der philosoph
war durch das video sah schon im 17
jahrhundert und albert einstein ergänzte
je besser man das wirken des universums
versteht
umso näher kommt man gut ob dem so ist
das frage ich meine gäste heute das sind
das ehepaar friedemann und christine man
herzlich willkommen
christine mann machen sie eigentlich in
der schule gut in physik ja so gut dass
ich zum schluss sehr oft in mathematik
und physik fehlen durfte und statt
dessen streichquartett spielen durfte um
fürs nicht so schulkonzert zügen
da haben sie wahrscheinlich ganz vielen
ich denke vielleicht besonders auch
frauen etwas voraus gehabt ihr vater war
der berühmte physiker und
nobelpreisträger werner heisenberg
standen sich gewissermaßen unter druck
in die naturwissenschaften gut zu sein
und da kam dieses ganze überhaupt nicht
es hat mich einfach von anfang an
interessiert das gab und schwester dies
nicht interessiert hat und so das war
anders verteilt über die familie
wie war das bei ihnen schritt um an sie
kommen aus der großen schriftsteller
familie sind der enkel von thomas mann
ihre beiden eltern sind musiker war bei
ihnen ein interesse dafür
naturwissenschaften als jugendliche
damals noch überhaupt nicht das ist
etwas was erst viel später als ich dann
in europa war als nicht nur als kind da
noch gar nicht sondern als erwachsene
und eigentlich besonders dann als ich es
tiere kennengelernt habe im hause
heisenberg sogar ein und ausgehen und
auch ein bisschen ein gegenstück zu der
mich nicht sehr zufriedenstellenden
theologie ein theologiestudium gesucht
habe und auch gefunden habe
da habe ich mich erst angefangen mit mit
physik besonders mit quantenphysik zu
befassen
sie sind ja in den usa geboren worden
haben dann in deutschland und in der
schweiz auch studiert zunächst musik
dann theologie und dann auch noch
psychologen wie viel haben sie denn
jetzt in ihrer auseinandersetzung mit
werner heisenberg und auch mit christine
mann von der quantenphysik verstanden
also es war immer sehr schweres zu
verstehen das ist eine sehr komplizierte
sache ist das kann ich heute noch sagen
wir sehen ja schon jetzt fünf jahre lang
in einem gesprächskreis wo auch ein
quantenphysiker maßgeblich an dem
mitwirkt und ich werde jetzt noch von
von monat zu monat immer wieder neu dazu
ich bilde mir ein schon damals mit 25
schon einiges verstanden zu haben und
auch im zuordnung zu philosophisch
theologischen grundfragen entdeckt zu
haben
aber es ist ein riesiges weiteres
interessantes feld was eben auch sehr
viele menschen davon abhält sich dann
wirklich damit zu befassen weil es so
kompliziert ist aber es ist eben wichtig
die menschen wie mich ist es ja schon
schwierig sich mit dem mit dem auto
modell auseinanderzusetzen und sozusagen
mit mit dem newtonschen weltbild
überhaupt irgendwie zurecht zu kommen
bediene man kann man anhand von diesem
von dieser struktur hier kurz erklären
was das atom modell ist wie dies noch im
gymnasium gelernt haben und wie ich
jetzt auch noch gelernt haben das ist
anhand dieses modells schon ziemlich
schwierig weil das atom modell was wir
in der schule gelernt haben bedeutet es
gibt einen kern der besteht aus protonen
und neutronen und ist darum kreisen
lauter elektron und natürlich haben wir
uns vorgestellt das sei alles richtige
so quasi materie kügelchen noch kleiner
als sandkörnchen so ungefähr
und ich war erinnere mich noch genau
dass ich dann mal gesagt hab das ja wie
das planetensystem ja ja und so das ist
einfach inzwischen weiß man dass das
unsinn ist
während hier das sieht ja so aus als
wären viele kerne zusammen das könnte
man eher als molekül modell er sich
vorstellen denn als ein atom modell und
das atom modell war ja im neunzehnten
jahrhundert hat sich das denken so
allmählich durchgesetzt dass es die
atome gibt und das ist dann diese
chemischen elemente gibt und das war für
mich sehr wichtig und in der physik hat
man dann wissen wollen wie das
funktioniert
und das hat dann eben zur quantenphysik
geführt weil man gemerkt hat dass alles
doch noch mal sehr anders ist als man
sich das ursprünglich vorgesehen
gestellt hat also das heißt auch man
muss eigentlich laufend seine
vorstellungen erweitern
ja ja und es wird eigentlich laufend ein
bisschen abstrakt
ich finde es nicht so kompliziert wie du
ist jetzt das geld hast ich werde fast
ins wort gefallen es ist sehr
faszinierend dass es also unterhalb der
atomaren ebene also und hat inzwischen
festgestellt dass die atome durchaus
teilbar sind aber dann ist es nicht mehr
diese materie sondern es ist dann sind
energie konzentrationen in einem
größeren feld und diese energie
konzentration die sind so stark dass sie
dann materie bilden und sehr beharrlich
sind aber die elementarteilchen selbst
die sind großenteils auch eben gar nicht
genau lokalisiert sie sind etwas was wir
mit den bildern umschreiben ein teilchen
oder eine welle also diese
uneindeutigkeit darauf kommen wir noch
zu sprechen fällt natürlich auf auch
wenn ich über ihre biographien etwas
recherchiert habe sie haben theologie
studiert sie hatten einige semester
theologie studiert da ist also nicht nur
die naturwissenschaft und bei ihnen
jetzt die musik was sie interessiert
sondern auch sozusagen was hat das ganze
dann für auswirkungen oder was hat das
für konsequenzen auf unser denken
vielleicht zunächst einmal die frage wie
religion ist sind sie beide eigentlich
aufgewachsen also ich selber bin ja ganz
merkwürdig weise in den usa wo ich bei
meinen eltern und bei meinen großeltern
aufgewachsen bin da eher waren nie kein
mit einem kein sterbenswörtchen die rede
von religion nicht mal von ethik mal
nichts
ich habe das erst viel später erfahren
dass ich
quasi auf wunsch meines großvaters mit
allen anderen mit enkeln getauft worden
bin von der ungarischen kirche wieder
eine ganz eigene dass eine kirchen in
die ist in amerika in der verbreitung
immer noch aber damals schon gehabt die
eigentliche die quecker sehr sehr sehr
offen sehr tolerant sind wo das quo die
gewissens dass das gewissen des menschen
im mittelpunkt steht also ohne dogmen ob
das jetzt nun auch überhaupt christlich
ist nicht christlich ist noch sehr offen
und ii karisch heißt es es lebt schon
seit bestehen dieses dieser gemeinschaft
zeit eine jahrhunderten lehnt die
dreifaltigkeit völlig ab es gibt nur
einen gott und fertig und jesus ist ein
prophet und meer immer etwas anders eben
nicht und diese diese
glaubensgemeinschaft gab es in
kalifornien und als meine großeltern von
princeton an der ostküste nach
kalifornien um zogen haben sie sehr
schnell mit dem in italien kontakt
aufgenommen weil die den flüchtlingen
die jüdischen flüchtlingen als europa
geholfen haben so hat sich in kontakt
gebildet und er war von anfang an hat
sich in diesem engen kontakt das
religiöse und das politische ganz stark
miteinander verbunden und das ist
sozusagen der grund aber davon wusste
ich als kleines kind an packte ich
nichts das habe ich erst sogar nach dem
tod meines großvaters gehört dass der
auf seinen wunsch alle seine vier enkel
unter seinem kaiser in seinem beisein
dort getauft worden sind die first you
materie church in los angeles und sie
haben herausgefunden warum das ein
anliegen war ja ja das war weil er
sowieso er kommt ja aus dem luthertum
aus dem europäischen her und hat das
aber ziemlich abgelegt gehabt man merkt
schon in seinem schrifttum dass das dann
auch mehr und mehr die also ethik und
auch in gewisse religiosität eine rolle
spielt immer mehr
aber damit unter dem schock des dass der
emigration des zweiten weltkrieges vor
allem im fernen kalifornien und dass der
krieg immer schlimmere formen angenommen
hat hat das ihn natürlich schon auch
eine innere stütze gegeben und er hat
sogar bis ein halbes jahr vor seinem tod
noch korrespondiert mit der mit dem
referent mit dem minister dem vater von
von los angeles und gesagt ihre kirche
ist mehr die am
am nächsten an meinem herz gewachsen ist
weil diese offenheit und diese toleranz
in alle richtungen gehabt hat sie hatten
ein sehr eng ist ein sehr gutes
verhältnis zu ihrem großvater wir haben
hier ein bild könnt ihr das zu diesem
bild sagen wurde das aufgenommen das ist
in kalifornien in einem haus in pacific
palisades wo ich dann eben meistens
vielleicht sagen wir so ein drittel der
zeit wenn er oder ein viertel ist pro
jahr dort verbracht habe von meinen
eltern beispiel unter jahren sich bei
san francisco mit meinen eltern aber war
eben daher auch sehr viel und das war
die ganze zeit seitdem ich zwei bin
eigentlich bis ich mit neun jahren das
ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen vorher
aber mit neun jahren dann für immer dass
amerika und damit auch das haus
verlassen
christine mann wie warten dass bei ihnen
wurden die religiös erzogen ja
ausgesprochen also für meine mutter war
es sehr wichtig wir sind aufgewachsen
mit abendgebet mit tischgebet und als
das dann zu primitiv wurde hat meine
mutter von den psalmen eigene gebete
dann als psalmen stellen gesammelt die
man bei tisch vom mittagessen vorliest
und so mein vater kam nur sehr selten
mit in die kirche man wir sind auch
nicht jeden sonntag in die kirche
gegangen das nicht ich bin öfters im
kindergottesdienst gegangen und habe das
schön gefunden
und wenn mein vater dann nicht mitkam
der kam an weihnachten kann man mit an
ostern manchmal aber ansonsten nicht so
viel
dann haben wir ihnen auch gefragt und er
sagte ja weiß dass der religion
das ist schon was ist schon recht aber
für mich ist das nicht so genau das
richtige
und wenn wir ihn aber gefragt haben ob
wir denn da mich an gott glauben würden
so als kinder so ein bisschen entsetzt
und man sagt so einfach ist das nicht
das ist viel komplizierter
und dann kam eine erklärung dazu später
später kam dann schon ein bisschen mehr
erklärung aber eigentlich er hat uns
selber wenig gesagt was er wirklich
denkt er hat nur gesagt dass also diese
religion für
mit ihren vielen bildern für viele leute
sehr wichtig ist aber er denkt eben
abstrakter und so zeigen die eigentliche
erklärung die haben wir mal zusammen
gehört auf eine dvb erst lange nach
seinem tod in einem interview mit eike
christian irisch evangelischen rund wohl
auch so eine ära geht wo er dann sagte
ja man also man kann mit der seele eines
anderen menschen mitschwingen wie mit
der zentralen ordnung und die zentrale
ordnung ist für ihn eigentlich so eine
vorstellung von dass das das ist was wir
einfach religiösen menschen als gott
bezeichnet würden oder so was
und er wurde dann von eike christian
dann gefragt ob er das nicht doch ein
persönlicher bord sei wenn man und dann
meint er nein persönlicher gott nicht
aber man kann zu dieser zentralen
ordnung in beziehung dreht man kann mit
ihr mitschwingen man kann kontakt
aufnehmen und sich sozusagen bewusst da
mit rein stellen also haben wir es
verstanden haben als das erinnert mich
sehr an das was der große jüdischen
religionsphilosophen martin buber gesagt
hat die ich und du beziehungen ist das
entscheidende und dialekte der
schnittpunkt aller verlängerte nicht nur
beziehung ist das uhr do
und das ist für ihn gott gewesen das ist
mir sehr sehr ähnlich sagt man kann von
verschiedenen seiten immer wieder diese
zu diesem ergebnis einen ähnlichen
ergebnis kommen
ich habe damals nach dem wer das gehört
hatten mal versucht das aufzumalen
irgendwie um mit mir klar zu werden und
habe also erst ich hatte damals ein
malkurs mitgemacht habe also erst mal so
foto hier ein porträt meines vaters und
daneben eine zentrale ordnung lauter
pünktchen also in sternform dann dachte
ich es ist ja eigentlich scheußlich
scheußliche vorstellung und dann aber
eine weile später wurde mir deutlich
nein man kann ja die mit dem
mitschwingen und zudem in beziehung
treten dann habe ich also einen
schwingenden vielfarbigen hintergrund
gemacht auch und so die beziehungen mit
gemalt und damit konnte ich dann leben
das heißt dieses mit schwingen können
das wurde dann für mich so dass ich es
akzeptieren konnte und das hat offenbar
auch einen ein ästhetisches moment darin
ja auch aber eben insbesondere das
moment der das schlimmste und der
bewegung und der beziehung und die
beziehung ist ganz wichtig eben auch und
das da haben wir dann noch ist das
auseinandersetzungen gehabt
ich hatte diese mit diese zentrale
ordnung war es eher eine vorstellung das
könnte was staatliches sein konnte ich
nichts mit doch das wäre so irgendwann
kommst dogma aber dann als ich hörte
jetzt erst eigentlich vor einiger zeit
dass das eben ein schwingendes momenten
ist und das auch in beziehung gesetzt
habe mit den touristischen sie diese ski
das schwing der schwung hat man ja so
übersetzen da dachte ja das sieht jetzt
für mich ganz anders aus sie sind ja in
einem protestantischen haushalte den
protestantischen familie aufgewachsen
und haben dann aber zum katholizismus
konvertiert was war der auslöser dafür
also ich hab schon während meiner
schulzeit mich immer wieder
ich bin ja soo zehn jahren in münchen
gewesen habe dann auch den katholischen
religionsunterricht von meinen freunden
er darüber gehört und so und habe mich
in meiner schulzeit schon überlegt ob
ich nicht katholisch werden wollte habe
es aber nicht gemacht weil der
religionsunterricht da bleibt doch sehr
abstoßend war und erst als ich meinen
mann kennengelernt habe der ja
gar nicht so lange vorher auch
katholisch geworden war
da habe ich dann bin ich mit
leichtigkeit zum katholischen glauben
über gewechselt und zwar so die
hauptsachen im katholischen glauben
waren zwei sachen in der evangelischen
religion war damals ist mehr als heute
noch die erbsünde betont und immer
dieses du bist ein sündiger mensch und
man kam irgendwie nicht davon los
es wird zwar dann immer behauptet es
gäbe auch bei den evangelen eine beichte
oder sowas und dass man könnte doch zum
fahrer gehen aber das war für mich das
richtige in die in der katholischen
kirche gab es damals noch den
beichtstuhl und mann gegen mann anonym
hin und konnte sozusagen sagen was ein
bedrückt und dann war es irgendwann auch
mal gut das war für mich eine sehr
wichtige sache und die andere wichtige
sache war für mich dass man in der
katholischen kirche kniete und in den
evangelischen nicht und ich fand das
einfach gegenüber einem gott die
richtige körperhaltung also das waren
für mich so die wichtigsten gründe
katholisch zu werden
bei ihrem mann war das ganz anders also
sie sind nach einer teilhabe 2009 sind
sie als der katholischen kirche
ausgetreten aber hat der auslöser waren
die dauer also für mich war es zwar noch
einen anlass
ich war schon seit langem seit
jahrzehnten innerlich schon integriert
wenn man so will
ich hatte zwar ich war psychologe und
psychotherapeut und fand das auch schon
eine art fortsetzung in szene
sagt mal einer säkularisierten
seelsorgerin man so wenig aber es gab
für mich religion und kirche eigentlich
in der zeit 68 besonders dann nicht aber
als dann dieser dieser deutsche papst
dann als deutscher dem holocaust
geschichte dann so behandelt hat das sag
ich hoffe die den holocaust geleugnet
haben damit in die kirche zurückgeholt
habe dachte ich das geht jetzt einfach
zu weit das kann ich nicht mehr sprechen
von von von von krediten ewig wenn ich
dem 16
die piusbruderschaft genau die toten
herein geholt hat
als als als naja warum auch immer jeden
fall ist das war für mich dann sozusagen
einfach nur der tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen gebracht hat und sie konnten
das gar nicht nachvollziehen
ich fand das auch nicht toll
natürlich aber ich fand deshalb gleich
aus der kirche auszutreten
die falsche reaktion weil ich denke
diese handlung auch der papst ist etwas
sehr menschliches sehr viel bares und
der unsinn ist einfach dass sich für
unfehlbar hält aber das tut ja der
heutige auch nicht mehr gut kehren wir
zurück zur quantenphysik und zu ihrem
buch das sie gemeinsam geschrieben haben
es heißt es werde licht
ich halte es mal in die kamera sie
hatten gesagt sie hätten sich fast 25
jahre lang nicht mehr mit der physik
oder die quantenphysik beschäftigt und
haben jetzt wieder den faden aufgenommen
warum also dass das war eigentlich
meinen impuls im jahr 2000 wurde
gefeiert 75 jahre quantenmechanik und
2001 war dann der hundertste geburtstag
meines vaters und da sind mir dann die
fragen wieder gekommen
die mir früher schon wichtig gewesen
waren
und zwar 1975 relativ kurz vor seinem
tod hat mein vater noch mit uns einen
spaziergang gemacht und wir haben ihm
erzählt was wir für die physik prüfung
lernen sollten
und wir hatten damals in münster
studiert und der fachbereich war sehr
marxistisch leninistische ausgerichtet
und deshalb lernten wir als
entwicklungspsychologie auch wie die
welt entstanden ist und es wurde eben
beschrieben dass die welt eben aus der
materie dann das leben irgendwann
zufällig entstanden ist daraus die
wahrnehmung und daraus die psycho und
dann unsere gene denken und dass das
alles also eigentlich rein materiell
basiert ist und das haben wir dann unser
vater mein vater erklärt und er sagte ja
genauso sehe ich das eigentlich auch das
heißt ich hab 1942 allein auf sein buch
geschrieben das manuskript liegt noch in
meiner schublade das war also noch nicht
veröffentlicht und da beschreibe ich die
entstehung der welt eigentlich genauso
nur die materie ist nicht das was man
sich unter materie vorstellt das sind
eben keine kleinen kügelchen sondern
materie ist eigentlich eine art energie
konzentration in einem größeren feld und
hat bestimmte strukturen und wenn man
eben in die ebene unterhalb der atome
eintritt und die elementarteilchen dazu
erforscht
dann merkt man dass das strukturen sind
von einer unglaublichen schönheit und
das eigentlich unsere welt mehr auf dem
geistigen basiert also strukturen sind
ja was eigentlich was geistiges eine
beziehung innerhalb der materie die aber
eben mehr ist als materie als nur
energie ist schwer zu erklären aber es
ist was eine geistige grundlage und im
letztlich hat plato in seinem
höhlengleichnis recht er sagt dass die
grundlage unserer welt die ideen sind
und eigentlich was geistiges bau damit
man sich sagt mathematisch strukturen ja
ich hab dann später auf verstanden dass
das eigentlich mathematische strukturen
sind das die quantenphysik sehr stark
mathematisch forscht sie sieht ja nur
das verhalten verhalten der
elementarteilchen auf irgendwelchen
nebel
tropfen platz platten wie sie sich
teilen und wieder neu bilden und so
weiter und wenn man das berechnet dann
entstehen
mathematische strukturen die man erkennt
und die deutet man deshalb ist unsere
reden über elementarteilchen schwierig
weil wir das immer mit bildern aus
unserer realen welt bezeichnet ich habe
das im buch aber doch sehr anschaulich
gemacht nämlich am beispiel eines holz
tisches und wir haben etwas glück an
einem holztisch
vielleicht können sie das mal kurz das
war sozusagen über die entdeckung der
tatsache dass das licht nicht nur als
welle existiert sondern auch als
teilchen wenn wir ein tisch sehen
dann können wir das nur weil der tisch
schon mal eine beziehung mit uns
aufnimmt nämlich über das licht was er
uns reflektiert das licht was armin raus
kommt hat in der regel ein ziemlich
weiße farbe hier ein bisschen gelblich
aber das ist eine große licht mischung
und der tisch ist so schon so
strukturiert dass er an
unterschiedlichen stellen
unterschiedliche mengen von farblichen
licht partikeln in unser auge schickt
und damit uns informiert hier ist holz
das licht verändert damit
erstaunlicherweise auch den tisch wenn
wir hier zum beispiel sehr lange ein
kästchen stehen haben und nach einem
jahr damals staubwischen wollen manche
tools öfters aber gut und das hochheben
dann ist hier auf einmal der abdruck des
kastens oft zu erkennen wenn es
richtiges heute ist das heißt da wurde
die umgebung durch das licht etwas
dunkler gemacht und hier ist ein heller
fleck oder und und umgekehrt das ist
also unterschiedlich und das war auch
eigentlich der auslöser dafür dass
einstein gesagt hat also der hat es bei
dem elektro
foto elektrischen defekt entdeckt bei
metallteilchen das kurzwelliges licht
richtig teilchen mit mit rausschlagen
kann und habe gesagt dann kann das licht
nicht nur eine welle sein wie man vorher
überzeugt war seit max sondern das muss
auch teilchen sein müssen auch teilchen
seien genau dieser diese dieser
dualismus sozusagen also dass eine sein
und das andere sein was sich eigentlich
nach unserer wahrnehmung und erfahrung
ausschläge
das ist ein wichtiger befunden dann
könnte vielleicht auch noch einen ein
anderes beispiel noch bringen das ich
mir vorgestellt habe
wenn ich den kreisel in eine richtung
drehe dann dreht er in der richtung in
der ich den impuls gegeben habe wenn ich
ihn in die andere richtung dreht andere
richtung aber auf der atomaren ebene
drehen sich die teilchen sozusagen
gleichzeitig in beide richtungen
das ist ja für die das ist ja für unsere
das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht mit
unserer wahrnehmung und unsere erfahrung
über ein ja wie mich vermied man etwas
das so fern von unserer erfahrung liegt
ja diese auf der sub atomaren ebene
diese teilchen die sogenannten teilchen
kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht direkt
beobachten sondern man beobachtet ihre
wirkung ihr verhalten und berechnet das
dann und dann drückt man das in bildern
aus und gerade bei dem teilchen welle
tourismus kann man das sehr gut erklären
mein vater hat die berechnung der
teilchen ermöglicht indem er sie als
teilchen verstanden hat und dann über
die über matrizen rechnung festgestellt
hat wie man das als davon ausgehend von
der teilchen vorstellung berechnen kann
und es war ein toller erfolg die
rechnung stimmt ein halbes jahr später
kam ernst schrödinger und hat gesagt nee
so nicht hier wie ich gehe von einer
welle aus und ich kann das genauso
berechnet dh man hat gesehen man kommt
zum selben ergebnis egal ob man vom wenn
van der bellen vorstellung oder von
teilchen vorstellung ausgeht und auch
bei
die komischen experimenten wenn man die
versuchsanordnung in einer bestimmten
weise macht bekommt man nachher ein
schönes interferenz bild wo man sie das
sind also eindeutig wenn das licht und
dann macht man die versuchsanordnung
etwas anders dann bekommt man auf einmal
ganz deutlich so ein teilchen bild mit
zwei teilchen häufen oder sowas und das
zeigt eben dass wir gar nicht wirklich
wissen was die wirklichkeit ist sollen
wir können nur in bildern darüber reden
und nur so schlüsse ziehen die halt
unserer begrenzten wahrnehmung und denkt
möglichkeit entsprechen die und die
wahrnehmung und denkt möglichkeiten sind
von unserer realen welt von unserer
makroskopischen welt her geprägt und
unsere ganze sprache ist davon geprägt
und wir können uns an das eigentlich
nicht darüber verständigen das ist die
mathematiker könnte noch anders die
machen sie es mit mathematischen formeln
und jetzt also unser physiker im
gesprächskreis der sagt dann manchmal ja
aber er ihr könnt die mathematik ja
nicht mit euch muss man eigentlich eben
über die bilder sprich eine andere weise
das vermitteln
das war für mich auch von anfang an eben
der punkt wo ich sagen da gibt es jetzt
gewisse mit gewisse parallelen zur
geisteswissenschaft zur theologie die
auch nur in bild sprechen kann wenn es
eine gute theologie ist die nicht bilder
also metaphern gleichnisse bilder
verabsolutiert zum dogma macht und
versucht noch bei anderen menschen
aufzuzwingen sondern wenn sie sagen jede
erfahrung die wir machen müssen wir
irgendwie in bildern kleiden um sie auch
für uns selbst wie auch im dialog mit
anderen verständlich zu machen und das
war in der klassischen physik eben nicht
so da waren da ging es ja um harte
gesetze im makro physikalischen bereich
das konnte man viel besser tränen schon
von einem geistigen von der theologie
jetzt als ich das das war eines der
ersten dinge die ich als fan von 20
jährige im hause meine schwiegereltern
gelernt hatte daher sage ich da gibt es
wirklich ganz neue
verbindungsmöglichkeiten einen
gemeinsamen nenner zwischen einer sucht
sofern voneinander entfernten dinge wie
theologie und physik ist das tat sich
das denken
davon dass wir die realität wirklich nur
über bilder erkennen können die wir
selber machen und die letzten englisch
auch sehr kultur abhängig sind sie
abhängig sind von der kultur aus der
welt stehen was werden so eine
entsprechung die sie als bild aus der
quantenphysik wiederfinden in der
theologie also inhaltlich nichts weil
das in der ganz verschiedene wege aber
allein die tatsache dass ich erkennen
kann in der physik gibt es eben in der
quantenphysik sind die das meinte ich
habe am anfang als ich sagte dass das so
kompliziert dass musste man erst mal
verstehen muss ich immer wieder neu
verstehen das ist ein ganz anderes
denken die tatsache dass ist auch dass
beide eben in bildern denken können
heißt es über die ganze wirklichkeit
egal aus welchen zugang heraus nur so
erkennen kann und dass wir zb von
teilung von welle sprechen das ist ein
erbe der der abendländische klassischen
physik das ist auch ein stück weit dass
das ganze denken ein erbe der der der
aristotelischen philosophien auf der ihr
die ganze theologie der letzten zwei
jahrtausende aufbaut und und es ist ja
typisch dass zum beispiel menschen in
asien aus der asiatischen kultur
quantenphysik viel leichter verstehen
können als wir noch weiß das weil das
eben weil sie eben nicht in diesen in
dieser harten form der aristotelischen
ding dafür also tischen philosophie im
versteht kategorien denken sondern sich
sie kreisen eigentlich mehr so
gegenstellen der 1 über die sie
nachdenken und das ist eine entspricht
diesem diesem weltbild der quantenphysik
die eben in diesem touristischen system
der dualen muss man sagen denn sind zwei
dieser komplementarität zwischen
teilchen und welle von anfang an mehr
der heimat erzählen in ihrem denken und
das ist das für mich faszinieren die wie
kultur abhängig nicht nur religiöse
anschauungen sieht sondern im letzten
endes auch dass das die art wie wir
physikalische gesetze ausdrücken auch
wieder abhängig sind von unserem denken
was wir aus der tradition unserer
eigenen kultur mitbringen
denken sie die quantenphysik oder
vielleicht besser gesagt die befunde aus
der quantenphysik gehörten einem
interreligiösen dialog noch mal ganz
neue türen öffnet bin ich ganz davon
überzeugt denn die diese die
krankenversicherung die grundlagen der
quantenphysik hat ihr haben ja sehr
viele konsequenzen
unser weltbild das weltbild was daraus
entsteht das ist ja sehr langsam hat
sich das entwickler am anfang dachte man
nur na ja also es hängt die die
ergebnisse unserer forschung hängt von
der beobachtung von seiner position ab
das war so der anfang
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert aber jetzt
inzwischen seit dem 3 1 durch die
weiterentwicklung der informations
begriff noch hereingekommen ist als
information als ursprung aller dinge ja
jetzt wird das jetzt wird es nun
wirklich interessant das verstehe ich
jetzt auch noch nicht genau das kann
sein stimmrecht sollten wir das erstmal
also man hat ja nachdem in den 20er
jahren die quantenphysik erst mal
entdeckt wurde so richtig oder
entwickelt wurde hat man versucht
allmählich rauszukriegen welche
elementarteilchen gibt es denn
und man hat versucht so diesen atom
aufbau genau zu verstehen und wann genau
berechnen zu können
aber und das hätte man seit max planck
schon wissen können
je kleiner die elementarteilchen sinn
geben man brauchte desto komplizierter
ist ihre berechnung und so dass diese
suche nach dem higgs teilchen zum
beispiel das ist so das letzte was
entdeckt wurde war ein großer erfolg
aber das was man in anführungsstrichen
gottesteilchen ja ja ja genau weil es
noch unbedingt nötig war um den atom
aufbau besser zu verstehen
das ist einfach ein teilchen was also so
kurz nur existiert dass man es
eigentlich kaum erkennen kann also ein
billionstel sekunde oder irgend sowas
und was so klein ist dass die
berechnungen dazu ganz ungeheuer
komplizierte sind und deshalb haben von
weizsäcker und dann in seine folge
thomas görnitz eigentlich gesagt wir
müssen nicht die kleinsten teilchen
suchen das ist ein irrweg sondern wir
müssen die einfachsten strukturen suchen
insbesondere wenn man sagt eben die
materie das ist eine energie
konzentration in einer bestimmten
struktur dann müssen wir die strukturen
suchen die dem zugrunde liegen
und das ist
informations eigentlich eine
zweidimensionale informationsstruktur
die man mit ja oder nein beantworten
kann und weizsäcker hat das noch so als
information verstanden wie wenn wir
miteinander reden dann tauschen wir
informationen aus aber das passt nicht
so physik weil das ist immer was sehr
subjektives was ich jetzt erzähle
verstehen sie anders als er und
vielleicht schaut ja und damit kann man
keine berechnungen machen und deshalb
macht der thomas görnitz gesagt es ist
eine vorinformation es ist die
informationsstruktur die
zweidimensionale informationsstruktur
als grundlage unserer materie und das
ist sehr spannend weil also um ein
elementarteilchen zu bilden war hat er
so dass berechnet ein elektron zb hat
zehn hoch 30
solche grundlegenden
informationsstrukturen das hat eine eins
mit 30 0 dran wo wir nicht mal wissen
wie man sie nennt und aber diese menge
an informationen die in jedem teilchen
nachher ist macht eben auch dass die
information in unserem leben und so für
unsere ganze welt ja die grundlage ist
und das kann man wieder wunderbar mit
der theologie verbinden nicht machst du
das mit sie haben ja sie haben ja beide
psychologie studie sie haben zudem noch
musik studiert und auch eben noch
theologie und auch einige semester
medizin
sie haben sie dieses buch zusammen
geschrieben ich stelle mir schon
aufgrund der materie und aufgrund ihrer
unterschiedlichen zugänge es als ein
unglaublich komplexer vorgang vor wie
man so ein buch schreibt wie den täter
vorgegangen
also es war so ich hatte ja zwei bücher
vorher geschrieben zwar sowohl die
religion so ist das versagen weltweiten
klinischen was haben wir da ich kann das
mit einer kurz zeigen
das war das erste das zweite wartet dann
eben an die musik das war im grunde ein
versuchtes selbe dieselbe fragestellung
nämlich wie weit können wir in
verschiedenen lebens gebieten einen
sehen einen lebenssinn entdecken für uns
entdecken aber auch im dialog mit
andersartigen andersartig denken der
menschen
wie können wir das im milieu sein
bereich machen ist religiöse
gleichrichter einzige gibt es nicht noch
eigene bereiche einstein hat ja diesen
schönen satz gebildet er sagte alle
religionen künste und wissenschaften
sind zweige desselben baumes das habe
ich doch habe ich erst später kennen
gerade aber so gedacht habe ich im
grunde so dann habe ich deswegen in der
musik jetzt genau das geld gleich auch
gesucht was ich für religion gesucht
habe
so ist sinngebung wie weit ist musik die
ist es nur eine ästhetische hat er nur
ein ästhetisches wert wellness wert
schönheits wert oder hat das auch einen
berg dass wir diese werte auch entdecken
durch das hören durch die rezeption von
musik durch die studien von musik durch
solche selber spielen und dann kam mir
die frage nach dem zweiten buch ja wie
ist es in der wissenschaft da hab ich
mich dann erinnert schon eben als mit 20
jähriger mit quantenphysik befasst zu
haben
ich habe auch immer schon seitdem ich
angefangen haben wieso um 2000 herum ich
überhaupt mal wieder mit der religiösen
spirituellen fragen zu befassen habe ich
mich schon immer wir haben wieder
zusammen noch mal über können liegt
damals gesprochen aber noch nicht so
viel
das kam ja dann sehr hundertste
geburtstag und so weiter und dann habe
ich nicht vergisst dass der dritte teil
der fehlt noch das kann ich aber nicht
ich bin kein physiker dann haben wir sie
mal überlegt wie könnte man so was
machen wir könnten mit einbeziehen
und da kam das angebot von hier ja wohl
wirklich zusammen machen da habe ich
gedacht schau einer an sich zwar nicht
physiker aber sie hat und wie sie keine
sind know how oder irgendwie von
herkunft und wir haben da schon viel
miteinander gemacht
probieren wir es machen dann haben wir
das ziemlich schnell aber eben zu
schnell angefangen da kannst du wieder
der anfang war so ich hatte das
vorgeschlagen und
akzeptiert und haben wir so ein bisschen
rum spezialisiert wie denn das buch
aufgebaut sein könnte
und ich dachte naja gut in den nächsten
14 tagen werden wir mal so
das aufschreiben und so nicht nachkamen
mein mann und sagt du ich habe hier
schon mal das inhaltsverzeichnis
aufgeschrieben du kannst gerne noch
wasser zufügen wenn du willst
habe ich etwas murrend erstmal
zugestimmt dann haben wir angefangen zu
schreiben oder haben es liegt wie man
das also dass man anfängt und drei tage
später kam ein mann und sagte 'du ich
habe hier schon mal was geschrieben
kannst dir mal angucken und wenn es so
geht können wir ja so weitermachen und
dann fand ich nee also so ist das nicht
ich möchte meine vorstellung sterne
stärker unterbringen und habe also ein
bisschen genutzt und dann hat man gesagt
ja eigentlich hast recht das nicht den
nächsten abschnitt schreibst du doch mal
und ich habe sowieso im moment was
anderes zu tun ich bin eben einfach viel
langsamer nicht ich bin nicht so geübt
im schriftstellern und dann habe ich
angefangen und dann haben wir wirklich
so gearbeitet dass angefangen vom
inhaltsverzeichnis was auch noch mal
sehr verändert wurde dass wir bei allen
sachen erst mal überlegt haben was
wusste rein wer schreibt ist und der
eine hat loos geschrieben hat dem
anderen per e mail geschickt so dass er
das schriftlich hatte und dann haben wir
strom regiert ergänzt gestrichen je
nachdem was wir fanden und wieder zurück
alles alle teile gingen mehrfach hin und
her und würden es wurde wirklich ein
sehr gemeinsames buch ist trotzdem eine
sehr strukturierte wir haben da wie sie
da vorgenommen ich möchte jetzt gerne
noch von ihnen hören sie haben eben
angesprochen sie hätten die suche nach
dem sehen in diesen verschiedenen
bereichen unternommen wo haben sie denn
sie ihn gefunden also gefunden habe ich
insofern ich als niemand den sehen
wirklich finden kann sondern eigentlich
mehr den sinn für sich selber oder eine
andeutung davon oder auch
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen verschiedenen
bereichen
so entdecken sagen ja hier ist hier
scheint wirklich etwas etwas sehr
wichtiges zu sagen ich glaube dass zum
beispiel immer als beispiel
es gibt ja viele konsequenzen aus der
quantenphysik für unser weltbild eines
zum beispiel am nächsten menschen ist
die frage haben wir einen freien willen
haben wir haben die möglichkeit sind wir
sind werden nun eigentlich so
eingestellt und die terminiert wie die
klassische physik immer sagt kann gibt
es das was der ablass einmal gesagt hat
zurzeit also für oder nach newton gesagt
hat also wenn es einem wenn es einen
einen außenstelle gibt die sozusagen die
ganze das ganze welt geschehen
überblickt dann kann der von einer kann
der von einem zeitpunkt auf den nächsten
egal wie weit der weg ich schon
schließen wie es dann genau aussieht
weil wir alles in die sich der
terminiert ist der ist so toll im
kopfrechnen dass das alles kam nicht und
das ist ja nun durch die wand wie sie
widerlegt worden es gibt die der
determinismus ist im markt im mikro
physikalischen bereich wirklich
widerlegt ist das causa hand prinzip und
damit das heißt wir können nicht klar
ursache und folge ursachen konsequenz
immer klar aneinander zurückgegeben was
mich ein feind klein sozusagen im super
automaten bereich könne das nicht mehr
ergiebig gehen ja nun mal aus aus
subatomare partikel letzten endes die
alles ist aufgebaut auf dem prinzip der
objekte und quanten und und quantenbits
und so weiter und das heißt also es gibt
einen einen neuen input gewissermaßen
wir müssen uns vorstellen dass das was
wir tun nicht immer nur schon geregelt
besonders auch eine gewisse freiheit
haben dinge so zu tun wie wir sie wollen
dass es das prinzip wie kreativität
intuition inspiration sogar sogar ahnung
weise sich vorstellen was in zukunft
geschieht was noch gar nicht geschehen
ist dass wir das können und es gibt uns
einen ganz anderen im ozean an einer
verantwortung nachgehen einer freien
verantwortung für unsere mitmenschen für
die welt für die umwelt und das ist eine
völlig andere situation als wenn man
sagt es ist alles immer schon alles vor
bestehen wir können uns zurücklehnen
wir können eh nichts machen das geschäft
der welt lauf geht irgendwie das fand
ich eine sehr wichtige punkt der mann
den man in all diesen bereich
aber wäre das nicht gerade eine
entsprechung aus der theologie also
dieser dieser sündenfall im paradies der
ja offenkundig dieser diesen freien
willen manifest die nur ja aber dass das
watt ist der ursprung gewesen wenn wir
aber sehen was jetzt zum beispiel dass
hier nur ein beispiel was im christentum
geworden ist da plötzlich landet dieses
theologie in der prädestinationslehre
von calvin gesagt alles ist vorbestimmt
das heißt dieser dieser causa liegt
dieser causa prinzip der in der
neuzeitlichen naturwissenschaft
vorhanden ist den kommt jetzt kommt ein
theologe und sagt im sechzehnten
jahrhundert es ist alles alles von gott
hervor bestimmt und das ist genau ein
punkt die theologie wieder aufbrechen
musste und dieses mit dem freiheit in
der theologie ist das so eine sache der
mutter hat ja auch gesagt die freiheit
eines christenmenschen
er ist es frei aber ist gleichzeitig
auch knecht es ist beides und ich denke
das ist ein wesentlicher punkt ist
vielleicht muss man noch erklären
inwiefern das mit der quantenphysik
zusammenhängen
das haben wir vorher noch nicht erklärt
also die elementarteilchen sind ja gar
nicht solche teilchen haben wir gesagt
sondern sie sind eben auch in einem feld
sie sieht nicht ursprünglich lokalisiert
und wo sie sich dann wenn es faktisch
wird lokalisieren das ist eben nicht
festgelegt sondern dass da gibt es immer
wieder unterschiede
der tisch hier der verrückt nicht
plötzlich weil die elementarteilchen
alle in dieselbe richtung sich
entwickeln weil es einfach so viel
elementarteilchen da beteiligt sind dass
man feststellen kann der bleibt schön
brav stehen aber bei den einzelnen
teilchen da gibt es eben durchaus den
zufall wird eine sache lokalisiert und
damit die unbestimmtheit und die
ermöglicht eben den grad der freiheit
denen die welt überhaupt braucht damit
aus der natur die evolution verschiedene
dinge entwickeln kann
damit sich das in der vielfalt
entwickeln kann und die auch wir
brauchen im denken um
neben einen freien willen zu haben und
die elementarteilchen verhalten sich
überhaupt an vielen stellen
ähnlich wie unser bewusstsein und es ist
ja auch die theorie dass wenn
informationen die grundlage unserer welt
ist dann ist geht das bewusstsein aus
derselben wurzel davor wie energie und
materie und hat auch sehr viel von den
elementarteilchen zum beispiel eben das
unbestimmte dass das viele sachen
gleichzeitig möglich sind in unserem
bewusstsein dass intuition das so
plötzlich neue ideen auftauchen oder so
das hängt alles mit dieser
elementarteilchen struktur zusammen und
ermöglicht diese neue freiheit im denken
und nur mit einem ganz wichtigen punkt
vorsichtiger punkt ist auch da wenn es
so ist dass da einfach große
zusammenhänge sehen
der fehler den wir aufmachen ist mir das
aber vom endprodukt dieser evolution mit
dem bewusstsein zu schnell wieder auf
die naturgesetze zurückgeben und dann
sagen also die quantenphysik beweist
also dass wir einen freien willen haben
und das ist ein grund falsch das ist
grundfalsch
was will ich werden sich sein formuliert
sonderlich wieder so fand das neue musik
ist dass sie die freiheit des willens
nicht ausschließt das hat mich die
kranken und die die klassischen für sich
ja immer getan und gesagt na ja gut ist
wenn es so spielen ergibt sie behaupten
wir haben jetzt rein will dann sollen
sie das denken das hat aber mit unserer
naturwissenschaften dann vergessen
nichts zu tun
die quantenphysik sagt der freie wille
ist nicht etwas was wir aus der
krankengeschichte beweisen können wir
können wir können einen grundlage
liefern wir können sagen die die es gibt
den determinismus ist sozusagen jetzt
gestoppt diese aufgabe ist jetzt in
bestimmten bereichen nicht mehr
vorhanden aber wenn wir jetzt daraus
schließen dass wir einen freien willen
haben wir ist das dann ist das eine
möglichkeit wir haben bei allen dingen
an philosophischen dingen in unserem
buch immer gesagt es ist nicht
auszuschließen es ist möglich man kann
sagen man kann daraus schließen aber wir
haben nirgends behauptet dass es das so
ist dass es einen freien willen gibt
oder dass die dass intuition etwas ist
was zwingend aus der quantenphysik
gefolgt das ist eine ganz wichtige sache
denn sonst passiert ist sehr leicht
das esoterische daher kommen und sagen
es ist ja quantenphysikalische erwiesen
dass wir nah tod erleben sie haben ja
das würde ich jetzt gleich als nächstes
interessieren sie haben sich sehr früh
im buch ganz klar von von der esoterik
abgegrenzt stichwort quantenheilung so
eins dieser dieser möglichen dieser
dinge die moment auch oracle aber
offenbar doch auch eine zeitgeist
treffen
wo stehen sie da sagen das ist es
überhaupt nicht das was wir meinen
oder hat es doch irgendwo etwas auch
damit zu tun also ich denke es ist sehr
wichtig dass wir ganz klar sagen es kann
etwas damit zu tun haben es ist auch was
mir was wir sehr schätzt auch vorschnell
umgekehrt als halluzination oder
wunschdenken mit sein
das kann eine gewisse wurzel ja dahin
haben aber es ist nicht so ist nicht so
dass es so ist dass wir sagen jetzt
haben wir denn das ei des kolumbus
gefunden jetzt haben wir jetzt wissen
wir dass es so ist das ist genau der zug
schluss das ist sehr verführerisch so zu
denken jetzt haben wir endlich was neues
jetzt können wir alles daraus ableiten
und da muss man unser müssen wir mit
unseren bedenken bescheiden bleiben und
sagen ja also neue möglich
der neue chance diese dinge mit
einzubeziehen wir müssen ganz klar immer
noch die begriffe trennen so wie wir
auch die methodik trennen zwischen
zwischen naturwissenschaft und geist ist
ja der der nach nach wie vor ist es so
dass in die natur wissenschaft arbeitet
sozusagen mit einem methodischen
atheismus das heißt gott darf nicht
einbezogen werden direkt methodisch das
heißt aber nicht dass wir trotzdem einen
atheismus überwinden können aber das ist
da nicht mit direct2d der der
naturwissenschaft sie haben ein buch das
wir früher nur ganz kurz angesprochen
haben
unter untertitel sozusagen mit
betrachtungen eines gläubigen warum
diese selbstdeklaration dass da habe ich
dann auch versucht im buch selbst zu
definieren das heißt also wer nur den
titel ließ der kritik kann es noch nicht
verstehen da muss also lesen gläubig
heißt für mich nicht die annahme
bestimmter lehrer
und ob man die gelehrt werden das ist
sogar das ist ein gegenbegriff für mich
sondern wenn man glaube jetzt jetzt
definiert als als vertrauen also
vertrauen auf dass es etwas gibt was wir
passen raum zeitlich nicht erkennen
können das ist so etwas gibt und dass
wir nur über bestimmte wege wie mädchen
denken metaphern dahin kommen dann würde
ich mich als gläubig bezeichnen aber
nicht im sinn jetzt wie die die kirche
lehrt und der pfarrer sagt und daraus
sind schließlich hat es nämlich jetzt an
das ist für mich ein glaube der der zu
wenig auf erfahrung auf eigene
persönliche erfahrung auf die
geologische erfahrung beruht wie ist das
bei ihnen würden sie sich auch als
gläubig bezeichnet was man unter glauben
versteht mich also es ist ganz klar dass
für mich eine beziehung zu einer
transzendent was ganz wichtig ist ob ich
jetzt da diese einzelnen aussagen glaube
ich bilde mir mein eigenes bild davon
ich verstehe es als metaphern zum teil
ich verstehe es als wichtige aussage
trotzdem sehe ich mich eigentlich als
sehr im christentum verhaftet und das
ist für mich so das zentrum meines
lebens aber eben nicht der glaube
sondern dass darüber nachdenken dass in
beziehung treten das meditieren und
solche sachen
und ich glaube dass diese sichtweise
dass jetzt immer eben dass man sich von
vertrauen und mich jetzt annahme oder
übernahme von dem was uns vor gekauft
wird dass das auch ganz wichtig ist im
verständnis der verschiedenen religionen
miteinander wendig und das klar haben
dann ist eigentlich zwischen denn dem
dem der intention die verschiedenen
religionen haben letztendlich gar keinen
unterschied der unterschied liegt in den
kulturen in der die religion sozusagen
aus der heraus entstanden ist und sich
verfestigt haben und das sind auch die
begriffe die wir dann rechthaber sich
gegen angriffe verteidigen und zu hören
man kann das so ausdrücken man kann es
so ausdrücken oder ich wirklich so aus
und dann können sich doch verständigen
dass da ein gemeinsamer nenner ist das
ist finde ich finde ich sehr wichtig für
diesen glaubens gewesen dass wir noch
einmal ein plädoyer für mehr
interreligiösen dialog
sie haben vorhin schon mehrfach diesen
interdisziplinären gesprächskreis
angesprochen was genau ist der was was
bezweckt er also wir haben ja den vor
fünf jahren etwa so gegründet weil ich
da so einem gespräch mit dem eine mit
dem anderen der dachte ich eigentlich
könnten wir diese ein biologe der
gleichzeitig mal theologe gewesen ist
daneben ein physiker dann wieder wenn
man anders man könnte du dich mal
zusammen bringen dann haben wir mal zwei
leute zusammen eingeladen und dann gegen
das irgendwann los dass eine der anderen
fragte würden sie eigentlich sagen dass
dass das leben schon beim beim virus
anfängt oder erst bei der bakterie hat
der bisher sehr schön geantwortet haben
sich verständigt
und dann haben die sich gut verstanden
haben dass einfache können ist doch mal
vielleicht zu treten dass man nicht noch
zu verteilen oder mit den mitteln beiden
mit den frauen dazu oder so nicht er
hatte ja aber auch verheiratet er hat
eine sozialarbeiterin zur frau wir haben
uns dafür zu fünf mal zusammen dass es
kaum noch jemand dazu und so ist dieser
gesprächskreis entstanden dann haben
eigentlich immer im grunde über die
fragen die in unserem buch zu kreisen
haben wir immer wieder jedes mal aus
einer anderen richtung an dieser frage
sieht daran gegangen und das ist auch
der grund warum ich am anfang sagte das
ist ein prozess der über jahre geht wenn
man immer wieder denkt jetzt habe ich
das verstanden
beim nächsten mal ach ne das ist auch
noch jetzt habe ich es verstehe ich noch
besser und das ist ein ganz hilfreicher
plattform sich so zu verständigen
ohne diese verständigt hätten wir das
buch nie geschrieben gibt es einen
output von diesem gesprächskreis gibt es
da noch in irgendeiner form protokolle
oder oder wo man sozusagen teilhaben
kann an dem was die einzelne leute aus
ihrer anschauung hereinbringen
es sind halt verschiedene bücher in der
zeit entstanden von dem thomas und
brigitte görnitz ist dieses von der
quantenphysik zum bewusstsein
entstanden wobei eben thomas görnitz
dieser physiker ist der auf dieses mit
der information als grundlage vertritt
als ein und seine frau ist
psychoanalytikerin und kann daher vom
bewusstsein und von und tierärztin und
von der medizin sehr viel beitragen und
das ist auch in der weise in
gemeinschaftsarbeit entstanden dass wir
anderen unwissenden dann immer wieder
die folge waren worauf er versteht ihr
das und wenn wir sagten
also das ist für uns nicht zu verstehen
oder so dann wurde auch wieder was
geändert um es verständlich zu machen
und das letzte buch von dem ganzen was
wirklich auch im gesprächskreise
diskutiert wurde ist und gott würfelt
doch der bekannte ausspruch von albert
einstein gott würfelt nicht ist
umgedreht als gottgewollt doch wo er
dann versucht eben diese
quantenphysikalischen sachen so und sie
bewegt sich doch ist auch noch sozusagen
da geben sie mir jetzt gleich das
stichwort wenn ich mir vorstelle wie
lange es gedauert hat von der erkenntnis
des galileo galilei bis sich bei uns die
die erkenntnis und die vorstellung der
erde als kugel gestalt verinnerlicht und
als allgemeinwissen durchgesetzt hat was
denken sie wie lange dauert es bis sich
die quanten philosophischen konnten
quantenmechanischen erkenntnisse in die
allgemeinheit muss ja auch schon vorher
vorausschicken kopernikus und galilei
was ja noch der dass er wirklich gemacht
hat indem er mit dem fernrohr das den
weltraum betreten hat kopernikus hatten
uhr gerechnet
aber wie lange das gedauert hat bis der
bis alles da ich von samos der kalte
krieg hat das ja auch schon gesagt nur
natürlich nicht berechnet und nicht so
da nämlich wissenschaftlich aber er hat
das schon philosophisch gedacht daher
hat aber mit den brunnen messungen das
schon ja da waren wir damaligen
naturwissenschaftlicher basis bekommen
aber das ist von der kirche oder
zugedeckt worden weil ich aristoteles
gefolgt ist er das eben nicht gesagt hat
und und
alle anderen top teams der hat ja das
noch der hat das ja auch behaupten das
ist das immer noch die die die sonne um
die erde dreht und so weiter das ist das
sind seiten die braucht die es braucht
bis sowas lange sich greift es gibt aber
auch geschichtliche widerstände wenn
eben diese strömungen die die kirche das
blockiert und deswegen würde ich sagen
die quantenphysik ist ja erst 100 jahre
alt war ungefähr das ist der anfang und
es hat sich schon so viel entwickelt bis
dass man in den schulbüchern alles ist
was wir bei thomas görnitz nachlesen
können da wären sie haben auch schon mal
so gesagt ach ja in 100 jahren unsere
urenkel wenn es vielleicht noch erleben
sie dann vielleicht damit zwar in der
schule aufwachsen
das dauert und dauert und auch weil es
weil ja nicht so gewohnt sind in diesen
kategorien zu denken möchte ich ganz
gerne noch was zu unserer esoterik
diskussionen vorhin ergänzen die
elektrizität wurde auch schon bei im
altertum entdeckt also wenn sie
bernstein auf weiche tücher gerieben
haben das dann funken sprühen das war
ein interessantes phänomen
und manche haben gesagt so was gibt's
gar nicht und so weiter es hat 2000 über
2000 jahre gedauert bis daraus eine
richtige wissenschaft wurde die wir
nutzen können und die unsere technik
wirklich ermöglicht ich denke auch in
der esoterik sind manche aussagen drin
die genauso nicht falsch sind wie damals
das wissen über elektrizität aber es
sind einzelphänomen und bis man das
wirklich erforscht hat man braucht dazu
ganz andere naturwissenschaftliche
methoden noch das kann auch 2000 jahren
noch dauern
aber wir können jetzt nicht sagen das
stimmt alles wir können aber auch nicht
sagen das ist alles mumpitz